so for the past 12 years I've been
obsessed with this idea that climate
change is an information issue that
computers will help us fight
I went from data science to climate
policy research from tech to public
service in pursuit of better data to
avoid the wasted energy resources
opportunities that lead to runaway
carbon emissions until one day running
in the streets with a friend it hit me
the same cars factories power plants
because emissions are wrecking our
climate over time also release harmful
local pollutants that threaten our
health right here and right now all this
time I'd focused on the long term
environmental risk when I should have
been up in arms about the immediate
health impacts of pollutants in the air
air pollution is a burning public health
crisis it kills seven million people
every year it costs five trillion
dollars to the world economy and worse
it robs us of our most precious gift the
years in our lives six month of life
expectancy in my hometown of Paris and
up to three four five years in parts of
India and China and in the u.s. more
people die from car exhausts than from
car accidents so how do we protect
ourselves from pollution the reason it's
difficult is an information gap we
simply lack the data to understand our
exposure and that's because the way we
monitor air quality today is designed
not to help people breathe but to help
governments govern most major cities
operate networks of air quality
monitoring stations like this one in
London to decide when to cut traffic or
when to shut down factories and these
machines like the computers from the 60s
that that filled entire rooms they're
incredibly precise but incredibly large
heavy costly so much that you can only
deploy just a few of them and they
cannot move such the government's air
pollution looks like this
but for the rest of us air quality looks
like this it changes all the time our by
RS street-by-street
up to eight times within a single city
block and even more from indoor to
outdoor so unless you happen to be
walking right next to one of the
stations they just cannot tell you what
you breathe so what would environmental
protection look like if it was designed
for the age of the smartphone for the
past three years my team and I have been
building a technology that helps you
know what you breathe and fits in your
hand flow is a personal air quality
tracker that you can wear with you on a
backpack a bike a stroller it's packed
with miniature sensors that monitor the
most important pollutants in the air
around you like nitrogen oxides the
exhaust gas from cars or particulate
matter that gets into your bloodstream
and creates strokes and heart issues or
volatile organic compounds the thousands
of chemicals and everyday products that
we end up breathing and that makes this
data actionable and helps you understand
what you're breathing by telling you
where and when you've been exposed to
poor air quality and that way you can
make informed decisions to take action
against pollution you can change the
products you use at home you can find
the best route recycle to work you can
run when pollution is not peaking and
you can find the best park to bring your
children out over time you build better
habits to decrease your exposure to
pollution and by tracking air quality
around them cyclists commuters parents
will also contribute to mapping air
quality in their city so we're building
more than a device but a community in
last summer we sent early prototypes of
our technology to a hundred volunteers
in London and together they mapped air
quality across a thousand miles of
sidewalk and twenty percent of all of
central London so our goal now is to
scale this work around the world to
crowdsource data so we can map air
quality on every Street to build an
unprecedented data base so scientists
can research pollution and to empower
citizen civic leaders policymakers to
support clean air policies for change
because this can
must change remember cigarettes in bars
it took decades of lung cancer research
and second hand smoking studies but
eventually we reach the tipping point
and we passed smoking ban laws we must
reach the same tipping point for air
quality and I believe we will in the
past couple years alone
governments have fined car makers record
amounts for cheating on emission
standards cities have passed congestion
charges or build bike lanes like Paris
that turned this highway right next to
my home in the middle of the city into a
Waterfront Park and now mayor's around
the world I thinking of banning diesel
outright by 2025 2030 2035 but how much
faster could we go how many lives could
we save technology alone will not solve
climate change nor will it make air
quality disappear overnight but it can
make the quality of our air much more
transparent and if we can empower people
to take action to improve their own
health then together we can act to bring
an end to our pollution thank you very
much
[Applause]